it's civilization time I'm joined by
will from Firaxis hey well how you doing
good to be here oh great to have you on
stage so I got to confess to you I'm a
big sieve fan I'm also big fan of sci-fi
anything science II and also space so
I'm a little bit excited about this game
so before we kind of have a look at some
brand new gameplay can you tell me just
why did you decide to take civilization
after sifting aside to go to space next
and not just uh a new version of the
classic Civ sure the time really was
right and ever since for access made
Alpha Centauri almost a decade ago we've
wanted to take the franchise back to
space and and the stars aligned and I
think we talked a number of years off if
he could do more puns that's great just
keep the buzz going that's right
so it was [ __ ] we had the team in place
and it was it was the right time to do
it so we were excited awesome okay so M
well then further like a SIF fan who's
played cry loft well I really want to
know is like what's new and what's the
same like if I pick it up right now what
am I gonna recognize and what is gonna
be like gonna throw me and make me go
wow this is like really quite an
experience sure the game is built on
Civilization v technology so if you've
played survive if you're a sip v fan
you'll know where all the buttons are
roughly right it'll it'll feel familiar
to you but right away it starts to
diverge stepping back a little bit
though I think civilization is it's
always a game about humanity finding a
home you know a historical Civ you start
off you know in the Stone Age with a
small tribe of people you settle and you
push back the darkness and you thrive in
this new place and that story transcends
time and setting and it's the same in
space so we took that same story to
space so now you settle on this new
world there are aliens and new kinds of
terrain that you have to negotiate new
technologies to discover but
fundamentally that story of humanity
over time is the same ok so what's
happened and what what's the the
backstory to this why did mine kind of
to leave earth so the game picks up two
hundred years from present day around
200 years from present day after
something called the great mistake which
we're sort of ambiguous about we won't
to make up their own mind it was a great
mistake accidently your whole world made
up it may have been one thing it may
have been several things but regardless
there was a humanitarian crisis on
planet earth the likes of which we have
never known and it destabilized the
nations of the world and the game picks
up right as we've claw our way out of
that
so it's an optimistic beat in this story
we've emerged stronger than we were the
nations are different but sort of the
same and they've all decided to go to
space in their own way
so the very first thing you do in beyond
Earth is decide who you want to be
obviously picking your sieve it's a very
important part of the civilization game
but in addition to that you get to pick
your leader your cargo the kind of
spaceship you want to take and the
people you want to take with you
oh wow and those decisions all kind of
contribute to this custom sieve that you
have throughout the rest of the game so
we're even from the beginning you're
controlling how you basically see this
new world as well that's right it's
quite exciting so you that's right I
guess that gives the player even more
room than before to to really hold their
own civilization that's that's quite
exciting that's right it's an incredible
amount of replayability that you get
from just these simple choices that you
make at the beginning and the AI is
making them too I'll tell you what let's
take a look at the game we go like I
think seven minutes of great gameplay
finish so let's bring that up but maybe
you can talk us through actually what
we're actually looking at okay so here
we are this is this like what units will
we go here what's going on
so we've just landed on Planet and you
can see that it's a very alien looking
place we have these deep rift canyons
with magma there these strange floating
rocks and this interesting these
interesting minerals that we'll explore
this is the tech tree one of the largest
departures from coercive instead of a
linear progression from left to right
now we have a technology web so there's
a lot of non-linearity and how your
civilization advances so we'll pick a
research there pick some production our
our city has to make something so we're
still very familiar right um so as a six
player this should look kind of familiar
to you so we have the basic sort of
worker Scout warrior at the very
beginning of the game but even those are
colored a little bit differently which
you'll discover as you play we've also
got this alien nest here that may be a
problem if we decide to antagonize them
the aliens are almost a sieve all on
their own
they're relevant throughout the entire
game okay they're not just like
barbarian and cats right barbarians in
traditional city for sort of early game
speed bumps but the aliens in beyond
Earth are a faction that you have to
deal with you don't have direct lines of
communication with them but depending on
how aggressive you are towards them or
you know the kind of land you encroach
on they'll react to that differently so
we've also got an explorer here that's
found an ancient ruin he'll he'll
excavate that for some interesting
rewards okay so this unit down here he's
like a Scouts idea Daisy
right actually he bypassed but you'll
see there'll be these alien skeletons
and ruins that you'll find above a
progenitor race that's been here way
before you discovering who they are is
an important part of the game too it's
actually one of the ways you can win so
every time you play are you essentially
on a new planet like I mean obviously
with picking from the same kind of
environmental possibilities everything
but it's a new planet each time right
that's the idea and it features three
distinctive biomes okay I'm so what
we're looking at here is the lush biome
but there's also the the arid biome
which is more it's like a desert Arrakis
sort of dude and planet and then there's
the fungal biome which is extremely
alien and strange and we're excited to
show you those very soon so in addition
to those three environments of course we
have our procedurally generated maps
which will put a lot of work into we've
we've even gone as far as to design some
of our map scripts to match what we
think may be on actual exoplanets that
have been discovered by Kepler and and
other other satellites so you have done
links a bit of the the real science oh
absolutely
okay we're a fans for fans of history
but we're also fans of history of space
flight NASA Rose cosmos the space race
you know the private ventures like
SpaceX and Elon Musk and all of that is
inspiration for the so if you're if
you're a big science fan you're gonna
there's a lot for you to get your teeth
into and beyond Earth yes okay I mean
let's talk a little bit about and the
combine how does it work if we got any
hope you got any combat in this barrel
here that we could maybe skip on to I'm
not sure but how does it work it is it
the same kind of same kind of gameplay
as in Civ that we used to so the basic
setup of combat is the same you have you
know two units you get a percentage
see ahead of time what happens so you
can decide if you want to do that or not
but the unit progression is different so
you don't unlock unit types in the tech
web so much as you unlock ways to
upgrade them so this is kind of a homage
to how unit customization worked in
Alpha Centauri instead of the very high
granularity customization of that game
what we have is a sort of upgrade trees
per unit class so depending on the kinds
of technologies you research in the tech
tree you'll unlock these these paths
through each unit subgroup this seems a
bit similar to any way of knowin acecomm
so you know I know system so in that for
example you could have make your armor
different I noticed in your tree there
there was things like nanotechnology and
so where do you pull from that must be
the real challenge I would imagine is
like building that Ted tree because
you're building in the future right I
mean the past you look back in history
and say well you know I know I need that
you need to get magnetism so you can get
a compass so you can build a big galley
to sail across the seas or whatever but
how do you do that then for for future
gazing well I think you've hit on one of
the most difficult design challenges of
this product which is to have a tech
tree and have a technology progression
that feels sci-fi enough but that's also
familiar enough that you can understand
what it does or that it's not so
fantastical that it's not believable so
our solution to that was to have
incremental progress starting from more
conventional technology so in the
beginning of the game you may research
robotics and computers and rocketry and
those are those are things that you
understand but incrementally from there
as you move out from the center you
start to get into much more alien or
science-fiction territory and that's
where the flavor really comes in who
okay what about diplomacy we're having
some diplomacy there we saw that
spaceship landing now understand this is
a different thing about beyond Earth
right so you don't all start at the same
time at you and your AI parts so what
explain that to me why is there this
wide you have this grace period where
you're on the planet first to get
settled we decided that one of the
themes of this game we wanted to be we
wanted a symmetry to be a theme in this
game so the aliens are one of the ways
that that that is there and then the
staggered nature of how the other civil
also contributes to this asymmetry
you are always first and the other SIVs
show up anywhere from turn zero to turn
fifty or so okay so this is my window
then if there's a window right and they
they land you know all over the map and
they may land close to you they may land
far away from you but they are
asymmetric because they they left later
they may have taken a slower ship they
took more with them they have different
stuff that they get to kind of balance
the game but in a different way than if
they were always equivalent of of Gandhi
cuz you know Gandhi's always
warmongering in the game obviously you
know I think he's killed me more times
than a kinder medic intervention but it
is there an equivalent is there space
candy space County they're not there's
not space condom unfortunately but each
leader has a personality and in addition
to that personality of course there are
these the loadout choices that they
picked at the beginning so you may have
encountered the equivalent of space
Gandhi or Montezuma or whatever you may
be my dad said face Kennedy this is too
good the point is we want then we want
each character to be a puzzle you have
to solve every playthrough you don't
want to assume that Gandhi's gonna nuke
you you want to you know that from past
playthroughs he's kind of aggressive but
you don't know how he's gonna be
aggressive this playthrough okay so
they're all colored by these
non-deterministic choices okay so
speaking of aggression that's one way
you can always win Civ but just kill
everybody
what are your victory conditions though
for beyond Earth well there's always
domination you you you can always kill
everyone and win the game that way apart
from that there are sort of technology
themed victories there's several of
those
there's transcendence which is a
callback to Alpha Centauri this is when
you discover that the planet is sentient
kind of like Solaris or something like
that and you figure out how to talk to
it merge your consciousness one ascends
trippy yeah trippy right there's uh the
the emancipation victory which you
reestablish communication with earth and
you build a warp gate and you send
military units through the warp gate to
conquer earth there's the promised land
victory which is the reverse of that
where you build the gate and bring new
settlers to the new world
all of these victory conditions are very
involved so it's not hit this number
it's do these things and protect this
stuff and build these things and it's
kind of like a progression that you have
to start you know 50 or 60 turn
before the game might be over so they're
much more involved analogous to like the
space race from Step five you build all
the parts and send the ship up fantastic
that yeah well thank you so much well
for coming on and showing us such a new
gameplay of asset beyond Earth I'm
really pretty excited about it
I think our chat has been as well I'm so
yeah thanks for coming on
they cans and what she could tell us
when's the release day when can we
expect your hands on it it's gonna be
out fall of this year and releasing on
PC Mac and Linux wonderful alright guys
well thanks very much for joining us for
the demo